Speaker 1: So there's an insane new report about
another one of the near complete disasters of
the Trump administration's handling early in
the covid-19 pandemic, and the news is that
Donald Trump floated the idea of sending
foreigners who were in the United States
and infected with covid-19 to Guantanamo
Bay detention center in Cuba, the very
same Guantanamo Bay detention center where we
keep and interrogate with enhanced techniques,
which some call torture. Those suspected of being
terrorists. They aren't always and that's a whole
other issue and question mark. But this is just
unbelievable. And I'm actually unsure which aspect
of this is most disturbing, but I'll get to that.
A Forbes reports that former President Donald
Trump early on in the covid-19 pandemic, floated
the idea of sending infected American tourists to
the Guantanamo Bay naval base in Cuba, according
to an excerpt of an upcoming book which adds new
detail to the behind the scenes chaos of the Trump
administration's controversial pandemic response,
explaining that nightmare scenario inside
the Trump administration's response to
the pandemic that changed history. The book
details a February 2020 meeting where Trump
shocked aides with the suggestion as White House
officials debate. I mean, this is like a it's like
satire. As White House officials debated how to
handle Americans infected with the virus abroad,
Trump reportedly asked staff members assembled
in The Situation Room whether Americans could
be quarantined on the Caribbean base, where
the U.S. also holds terrorism suspects in the
infamous Guantanamo Bay prison. Don't we have an
island we own? The president reportedly asked,
eager to keep the U.S. numbers low. What about
Guantanamo? The excerpt says aides were stunned,
but Trump still brought up the idea a second
time before it was quashed by staff members,
citing the poor optics of housing Americans near
the prison. Now, when this was initially reported,
it seemed as though by American tourist,
Trump meant foreigners. This seems to mean
Americans who went abroad and came back with the
virus, Americans, which it's insane either way,
but it's sort of like an additional layer
of insanity. The book, which is based on
interviews with roughly one hundred and eighty
people, including senior White House staffers and
government health leaders, is set to be published
June. Twenty nine representatives for Trump did
not immediately respond to Forbes requests
for comment. Trump reportedly said, we import
goods. We are not going to import a virus. Also
reported in addition to the exchange about Gitmo.
The Washington Post published excerpts of the book
recounts some of Trump's complaints about testing.
Testing is killing me. He reportedly claimed in a
March phone call to then HHS Secretary Alex Azar
complaining. I'm going to lose the election
because of testing. That's been widely reported
that Trump said we've got to slow testing down.
It's sort of like you've got to stop pregnancy,
just stop testing for it, even though that doesn't
really stop a woman from being pregnant. If you
don't get a pregnancy test nine months later,
there's still a baby. Trump's idea was just
don't test for covid. So I'm actually unsure
what is the craziest aspect of this? Like,
there's the xenophobic aspect. If you interpret
this to mean foreigners who come to the U.S. and
have covid. But when you actually look into it
more deeply, it seems Trump meant Americans who
came back from vacations with covid number two.
Is the legal aspect the most concerning? Like,
is there any legal framework for taking someone
with a virus not suspected of any crime?
Even when someone is suspected of a crime, we
can debate whether they should be sent to get MO,
you know, foreign enemy combatants and that
legal infrastructure, a legal American citizen
or permanent resident who just has
a virus, there's the legal question
about sending them to Guantanamo Bay. But
for me, the most concerning aspect of this
is how idiotic is it to think that sending people
with the virus to Gitmo would otherwise prevent
the pandemic in the U.S., where you can say
we will just go forward? Normally we don't
have to do anything differently, which was
Trump's approach during those early months
other than sending Americans who come back
with the virus to Guantanamo Bay. For me,
that's the craziest part. The legal questions, of
course, the moral ethical questions. Absolutely.
The xenophobic aspect to this, if you interpret
it to mean foreigners, those are all crazy things.
But the really wild part is it, again, goes to the
idea of Trump's fundamental misunderstanding of
we don't need to do anything other than send
people to Gitmo if they come back from their
vacation with the virus, as if that would have
prevented the pandemic. We know that Trump was
totally misguided on all aspects of this,
and ultimately we know how that turned out.